I'm confident I've got the best bank CEO
job in the world and maybe one of the
best CEO jobs that's Greg Becker the now
former CEO of Silicon Valley Bank in
2021. two years later Federal Regulators
seized control of the lender as it stood
on the brink of collapse this is a
classic Bank Run and when the blank run
starts you don't want to be the last guy
and wondering what happened so how did
we get from this to this
[Music]
Silicon Valley Bank was the US's 16th
largest bank
with about 212 billion dollars in assets
it was a fraction the size of JPMorgan
Chase the biggest lender but it had an
outsized influence in Tech which is 10
of the US economy
let's go back to how it all started
sdb was founded back in 1983 by three
businessmen the founding myth is that
the idea came up during a poker game but
that's only half of the story Bob
Medeiros one of the co-founders was
teaching a class at Stanford and one
question kept coming up a lot of them
came and wondered how they could get
financing from Banks because they just
weren't if you had an idea The Venture
Capital was sworn around yet I got the
idea that hey maybe just maybe after the
Reagan came in and eased up the
regulatory structure
that there could be a financial
institution so from the very outset
Silicon Valley Bank intended to work
with companies who
otherwise struggle established lenders
like a Wells Fargo or Bank of America
the other thing that most Bankers don't
understand that I think people here in
the valley understand you know
somebody's got a product then the
products outdated the company goes out
of business they don't realize the r d
that goes into the next product and and
the intellectual properties that was
huge for the tech industry back then
Silicon Valley was mostly about Hardware
think makers of silicon chips and early
PCS like Intel and Hewlett Packard but
svb was part of a new wave of investing
rather than focusing on how profitable a
firm is Tech investors instead often
prioritize how fast it's growing they
assume sometimes naively that at a
certain point the company will stop
reinvesting its earnings in things like
acquiring new customers and instead
become profitable Flash Forward a few
decades and svb is riding the coattails
of a booming Venture Capital industry
that it helped to facilitate Venture
Investments approached 330 billion
dollars in 2021 nearly doubling from a
year earlier
at this point svb liked to say that it
was doing business with about half of
All venture-backed Tech and Healthcare
startups in the U.S I don't think there
could be anyone who's touched the
Venture Capital industry in the last 40
years who doesn't have some exposure to
Junior type Banks like to svb and
signature and a whole host of others
it's become part of the fabric of the of
the Venture Community the bank went from
17 billion
2011 to 189 billion a decade later it
grew faster than any Bank in the S P 500
and it wasn't even a member of the index
now Banks make money by taking in
deposits and lending them out at higher
rates as well as investing them and
typically government bonds like
treasuries rank among the safest
Investments out there so the bank plowed
tens of billions of dollars into them
long-term government debt didn't
generate much interest or yield and as
long as interest rates stayed low pretty
key detail here they wouldn't lose their
value the company was aware of the risk
in late 2020 the bank's asset liability
committee received an internal
recommendation that it should invest new
deposits in lower yielding short-term
bonds just in case interest rates
increased but that would have cost
millions and Executives frowned on the
idea instead they continue to invest in
the higher yield bonds
during the Obama Biden Administration we
put in place tough requirements on banks
like Silicon Valley Bank and Signature
Bank including the Dodd-Frank law to
make sure that the crisis we saw in 2008
would not happen again
unfortunately the last Administration
rolled back some of these requirements
as a VC industry grew more influential
Becker and a slew of leaders at other
Regional Banks pushed for deregulation
they got what they wanted the strict
Capital rules introduced after the great
financial crisis would only be reserved
for the Mega Banks this teed up Silicon
Valley Bank to invest in Securities
without a lot of government oversight
which was okay until inflation started
picking up we finally got the First Fed
rate hike of this cycle seven hikes for
this year do you really think that a
tightening cycle is not going to have
any effect on the real economy the FED
embarked upon its most aggressive
interest rate hike campaign ever raising
its Benchmark rate seven times last year
that changed everything and it created
two big problems for svb
first it became a lot harder for
startups to raise new money so those
that weren't already profitable the same
companies for which the bank had been
founded became more likely to draw down
their existing funds prompting svb's
deposits to drop by 16 billion dollars
in 2022. that was the most on record
second the value of svb's bond
Investments declined also by 16 billion
dollars because investors could now buy
bonds with higher yields those with a
low yield were less valuable that
doesn't matter much if clients keep
their money in the bank but a lot of
them were pulling it out these two
problems combined meant losses that were
purely theoretical were becoming all too
real in a worst case scenario Sab
wouldn't have enough money to cover
everyone's deposits
on March 8th it made an announcement
that shocked the market it sold 21
billion dollars of its assets including
a lot of that government debt
essentially to make sure it could fund
all those withdrawals and it did so at a
loss of 1.8 billion dollars to plug the
Gap it was looking to raise more Capital
by selling billions of dollars of shares
that sparked a panic no stock has been
hurt more than svb financial group today
the shares plunged you the most in more
than two decades after the parent of
Silicon Valley Bank announcing the stock
offering and well uh getting rid of some
things that are on its balance sheets a
lot of concern out there right now it
was an old-fashioned Bank Run with a
digital twist
lions were forming around the block
Founders iPhones lit up with texts
urging them to go run for the exits
pouring fuel on a fire
on March 9th depositors tried to pull 42
billion dollars from Silicon Valley Bank
a equivalent to 29 million dollars a
minute by the end of the day the bank
had a negative cash balance of 958
million dollars the stock tumbled 61
that wiped out 9.6 billion dollars of
market capitalization
oh
big thing to remember here the U.S
banking system relies on the confidence
of its depositors if that disappears and
everyone runs to withdraw their money at
the same time it all falls apart so
ensuring that depositors can access
their money is in the best interest of
well really everyone government VCS
employees on payroll the list goes on so
on Friday March 10th Regulators at the
FDIC seize the business making it the
biggest U.S lender to fail since 2008.
Americans can have confidence
the banking system is safe your deposits
will be there when you need them by the
following Monday a fix kind of had been
cobbled together apart from a deal with
HSBC by the bank's yarn for a nominal
one pound about a dollar twenty no buyer
had yet been found but the government
pledged that depositors would be made
whole even those who had more than the
250 000 limit at the bank startups
around the world breathed a sigh of
relief yes there were concerns that the
ultimate owner of svb wouldn't be quite
as willing to work with riskier tech
startups as its predecessor but at least
the startups had their money and that
was something to be grateful for
[Music]
foreign